i am 24 years old i am one of the five
people who are stuck in the flood
i can never forget the 25th of august it
was a horrific day for us it was early
morning and it was raining heavily so i
decided to move my vehicle to a safe
place when i came down my friends also
joined me we were moving towards the
bazaar with our vehicles
we saw the torrent heading towards us
so we ran and climbed a big rock to seek
refuge we were soon surrounded by raging
waters
we called the deputy commissioner office
to tell them that we were stuck on a
rock and for god's sake to help us
because our lives were at stake
for five hours but there was no response
my friends were all panicking and were
crying
bilal was scared and called his father
and told him baba
i have been a disobedient son please
forgive me i will not survive i am in a
struggle of life and death pray for me
were also crying and calling their
families to tell them that their lives
were in danger and to pray for them
anwar offered his prayers on a rock
while the others were reciting verses
from the quran
just across from our villagers and
family members were trying to throw
ropes to save us my friends told me i
should grab their open go first and they
tied me up
suddenly a big wave came smashing on the
rock and i was able to cling onto the
rope but all my friends were swept away
it is very painful for me that i could
not do anything for my friends
there was a helicopter for rescue my
friends would still be alive and with me
my friends were lost because of
negligence of the authorities
when i got out of the tour and my family
thanked allah and told me that our home
vehicles shops and fields were all gone
after the incident i felt in my heart
that i should stand up for my people to
the last breath and by allah's help to
serve my people
our pakistani brothers and sisters are
sending aid and i am helping with
distribution of food and medicine it is
my duty i have nothing left but i will
do whatever i can for my people i have
dedicated my life to my people